[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN SEALES: Having
left her job as a CIA
analyst for ethical reasons,
newly appointed Secretary
of State Elizabeth
McCord returns
to the public life at the
request of the president
after the suspicious
death of her predecessor.
This is the beginning
of the show.
Valued by her boss and
her apologetical leanings,
knowledgeable of the Middle
East, language skills,
and creative thinking, Elizabeth
drives international diplomacy,
battles office politics,
and circumvents protocol
when negotiating national
and international issues.
At home, politics and
compromise take on a new meaning
with her supportive husband
and three bright kids.
We're going to roll a
little sizzle for you
to get going before
season 4 here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Sunday, October 8,
"Madam Secretary" is back.
[GASP]
- Help, somebody!
- 22% of Americans believe
you're guilty of murder.
- Don't miss the star-studded
season premiere event.
- If I was going to
have someone killed,
I'd at least be a little
discreet about it.
- "Madam Secretary."
Season premiere CBS
Sunday, October 8.
[END PLAYBACK]
All right.
Please help me welcome to the
stage Morgan Freeman and Lori
McCreary.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
MORGAN FREEMAN:
I'm Morgan Freeman.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
[LAUGH]
MORGAN FREEMAN: Lori McCreary.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Have a seat there.
MORGAN FREEMAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Whoo!
ALAN SEALES: Thank you.
MORGAN FREEMAN: He told me
to take the middle seat.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: I want--
when I was preparing
for this event,
I was kind of
conflicted, because I
didn't know how deep to dig
this into the story of "Madam
Secretary" and the CBS show.
And what I decided,
the direction
I decided to take this in was
to be more about the two of you
as a duo, as a pair, as a
producing team, because--
well, I guess I should
let you tell that story.
Like, what is your
production company?
How did the two of
you get connected?
MORGAN FREEMAN: I'm
not going to tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: And
we're out of time.
LORI MCCREARY: Oh.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: Back in
the early '90s, '90--
[GIBBERISH]
--'92, we did a movie.
And she was the producer,
I was the director.
LORI MCCREARY: I hired him.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: It's true.
And we just--
I don't know, I had the same
mindset, frame of reference.
What to do, how best
things should work,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And we made a pretty good movie.
And a couple of years
later, we were talking.
Somehow we held
on to each other.
And I remember--
I don't know if I asked Lori
what it was that she wanted
to do or what, but at
the time, Dustin Hoffman
had told me, listen.
You want to get your own stuff
done, form a film company.
That's easy to do.
You can just form a film company
or call it a film company,
and it's just a name
on a piece of paper
that you register somewhere.
And I did, because then you can
acquire and store properties.
And so in this
conversation with Lori,
she said, what I really want to
do is run my own film company.
And you get one of those
(HIGH-PITCHED VOICE) ding
things going on.
I said, well, guess what?
I have one, and I need
somebody to run it.
So that was the beginning of it.
OK, said, what do
we call ourselves?
Well, depends.
What do we want to do?
Well, we want to make
movies that speak truth
and what's that--
LORI MCCREARY: Enlighten people,
enhance the human experience.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah, that's it.
[LAUGHTER]
So I said, Revelations.
She said, great.
She's Christian, so she
immediately went to the Bible
with the idea.
And I thought, that's not it.
We're revealing.
This is-- revelation
means to reveal.
So there we are,
and here we are,
I don't know how
many years later.
Because I can't count.
I don't do math very well.
How many?
LORI MCCREARY: 20.
MORGAN FREEMAN: 20.
LORI MCCREARY: 20 since
we started the company, 25
since we made the movie.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
Wow.
And there you go.
LORI MCCREARY: I was 10.
[LAUGHTER]
Can I add a little
color to that?
ALAN SEALES: Oh, please.
LORI MCCREARY: So we--
we made a movie in Zimbabwe in
1992, which was a little crazy.
And I was a computer scientist
before I became a producer.
[CHEERING]
[LAUGH]
[APPLAUSE]
MORGAN FREEMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
LORI MCCREARY: A programmer.
C++ programmer.
I loved programming.
[CHEERING]
I was really good at it.
I was really good at it, but I
really also was a storyteller.
From when I was eight
years old, I did theater.
And I was sitting at the
computer coding one night,
and I thought, I
really want to do
something that tells stories.
And at the time, I had started
a software company that helped
lawyers bill people more.
So I was, like, conflicted.
[LAUGHTER]
And so when Morgan and I were
in Zimbabwe making this film--
and by the way,
Paramount Pictures
sent me and my
producing partner there
without any other
producers only because I
went into Paramount Pictures
to the head of production,
because he was going
to grill me to see
if I knew what I was doing.
I went in with a compact
dual drive computer
with the first budgeting and
scheduling software program
on DOS.
And he thought I was
a genius, because he'd
say, well, you need to cut
four days out of your schedule.
And I'd put minus 4,
and tell him how much--
we're going to save $436,000.
And he was writing
down all these numbers.
And what I found out much
later was Paramount Pictures
was still doing all
their budgeting on paper.
You know, with calculators.
So they thought I was,
like, this genius producer.
And all I really knew how to
do was, like, search for grip
and change a number on a budget.
[LAUGHTER]
So it was really great to
have the experience I had.
And when Morgan
and I were talking,
Dreamworks was just starting
their interactive division,
and I was talking to them
about going there and working.
And I was conflicted,
because I love technology.
I love what it's
doing to our industry.
And I was really--
but I really wanted
to go more into
storytelling, but I
didn't want to let
go of the technology,
and so this was the
conversation we were having.
And when he said,
oh, would you like
to start a film company,
what I said was,
what would that look like?
And what I was thinking on
the inside was, oh my God!
[LAUGHTER]
So it was a match
made in heaven.
He's a great, great partner.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Let him
talk about me for a while.
[LAUGHTER]
LORI MCCREARY: Go.
ALAN SEALES: I've got a
whole bio section on you.
MORGAN FREEMAN: I like that.
[LAUGHTER]
What one of the lead-ins to
this whole movie-making thing
that we did was
the year before, I
had worked with Clint Eastwood,
the first movie I did with him.
And Clint Eastwood as a
director was like this.
[SNAPPING FINGERS]
He's always on time.
He was always on budget,
because he doesn't fool around.
So we brought our picture
in on time and under budget.
LORI MCCREARY: Under budget.
Like, $800,000 under budget
because of the director.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Because
of Clint Eastwood.
LORI MCCREARY: And this--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Quick teacher.
LORI MCCREARY: What I didn't
know until my first film,
I thought every film started
at 6:00 in the morning
and wrapped by 3:00
in the afternoon,
because that's the
hours that Morgan kept.
So my first movie, I
thought, this is great.
And then the next movie we
did, it was 14-hour days.
And I was thinking,
what are we doing?
I need Morgan to direct again.
ALAN SEALES: I just love that
I've been up here for, like,
seven minutes and
asked one question.
LORI MCCREARY: Sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: All right.
Ask another one.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Well, you're here
to promote "Madam Secretary,"
among other things.
So tell us about-- tell
us about this show.
Why did Revelations
Entertainment
decide to create and
produce "Madam Secretary?"
MORGAN FREEMAN: Good idea.
I mean, good question.
It also was a good idea.
[LAUGHTER]
Looking around for something--
Lori should actually
start talking
on one of these situations,
because I draw blanks.
But I know we were looking for
an out, some way to make money,
to work.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: As one should.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
And we talked to--
LORI MCCREARY: Nina Tassler.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah, we had
lunch with Nina Tassler of CBS.
And I don't know--
she said come up with
something, didn't she?
LORI MCCREARY: She Said yeah.
We had lunch with Nina, and
I said, you know, filmmaking,
the middle class of
film was drying up.
The "Million Dollar
Babies," "Shawshanks,"
those kind of movies
are really hard to make.
And five years
ago, hard to make.
And so we thought, maybe we
should get into television.
So I basically just-- we had
lunch with her and we said,
how do we get into television?
And she said, come back to
us with a character that you
can spend 100 hours
with, or a place that you
can spend 100 hours in.
And being filmmakers, like,
two hours, I was like, OK.
And we went away and
thought about it.
And the real story of the
inception of the idea,
I was sitting with our head
of development at a bar
next to our office, and
Hillary's Benghazi hearings
were on, and you know, this
image of her doing this.
MORGAN FREEMAN: What difference
does it-- at this point,
what difference does it
make, that statement?
LORI MCCREARY: And-- yeah.
And I thought, oh
my gosh, because I
figured she'd be going
home that night, talking
about what happened.
And I thought, OK.
We could spend 100 hours with
a female secretary of state
who has a family,
and what's going on?
MORGAN FREEMAN: By that time,
she was the third one we'd had.
And all three of them had
left an indelible mark
as our country's
representatives.
So boy.
There we go.
We got strong women.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
I mean, Madeleine
Albright, Condoleezza Rice,
and Hillary Clinton.
Yeah.
So what is the truth that
you were trying to show in--
like, in the show of
"Madam Secretary," what
truth are you trying to reveal?
MORGAN FREEMAN: How government
really, really works.
ALAN SEALES: So is it based on
a lot of, like, true stories
that you knew about?
MORGAN FREEMAN: No.
[LAUGHTER]
She says, I say.
Well, you have to--
LORI MCCREARY: Inspired.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
We have to use current events.
They inform the
stories that we tell.
But you know, we
make up shit too.
LORI MCCREARY: Right.
[LAUGHTER]
President Clinton
came to us one time
and said he loved our
show, "Madam Secretary."
And then he said, but I wanted
to be the character Henry,
because he's an agent
and a professor.
He's like, I wanted
to go into the field.
I want to do that.
So it's not really true.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
You guys are good
at name dropping.
It's fun.
Yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Well--
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, when Bill
Clinton came and called me
the other day, I was just
like, what's up, Bill?
[LAUGHTER]
It just happens.
MORGAN FREEMAN: I know Bill.
ALAN SEALES: I know you do.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: I've
known him since he
was governor of Arkansas.
ALAN SEALES: Did you really?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Wow
And did he influence
any of the show at all?
Do you go to him for--
MORGAN FREEMAN: No.
No, no no.
ALAN SEALES: --her
secret stories?
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: No, no, no.
No, no.
ALAN SEALES: No?
You can't say that?
MORGAN FREEMAN: We can't--
you know, because we can't
use, really use them, you know?
It adds too much
something-- what?
Come on, help.
LORI MCCREARY: Pressure.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Pressure.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: I love
how you complete
each other's sentences.
LORI MCCREARY: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: Wonderful.
And both of you wear so many
hats, both in real life--
well, it's all real life.
But in--
[LAUGHTER]
I guess outside of the show
and inside of the show,
specifically.
So Morgan, you're executive
producing, obviously.
And you have a few--
you have a role that you
reprise every now and then.
And then now you're about
to-- or have directed
your third episode of it?
MORGAN FREEMAN: I have.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah?
So when do you look
at this and say, like,
I'm going to be that guy, or I'm
going to direct this episode?
How do you go
through that process?
MORGAN FREEMAN: No, we've
decided that I'm-- this is
going to be a tradition.
I will direct the first episode
of each season that we're on.
So hopefully, we have about
eight more seasons to go.
By which time, I'll
be ready to retire.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: And why do--
or why do TV shows--
I've always wondered this-- why
do TV shows switch directors
so often?
LORI MCCREARY: It's
a very good question.
We shoot every eight days.
We're either prepping
the next episode,
shooting the current episode,
or editing the episode before.
So at a minimum, you
need three directors.
If you had three
directors, they'd
be working all the way
through, and it's hard--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Day and night.
LORI MCCREARY: Yeah, and it's
hard to find three directors
who want to do the same show.
And so we alternate directors.
The first season, we had
17 different directors
doing 23 episodes.
This season, we have about 14
directors doing 23 episodes.
So many of them do two,
and over half of them
are female, which
I'm very happy about.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: So 22, 23
episodes per season.
That's a lot.
LORI MCCREARY: Yes.
Every eight days, we get a
new script, a new director,
and a new story.
ALAN SEALES: So
typical season now,
I mean, especially with
the on-demand generation,
you get, like, eight
or 10 or 12 episodes.
LORI MCCREARY: Yeah.
That would be nice.
[LAUGH]
ALAN SEALES: So was
it your decision?
It doesn't sound like it to do--
LORI MCCREARY: It's network.
Network television is
typically 20 to 24 episodes,
and it's the very clear season.
The things that are happening
in streaming and cable,
it's kind of a
year-round business.
And you can do six
episodes, you can do 12.
It's a little bit amorphous.
And you usually get
more time to spend.
We have eight days to shoot.
Sometimes they have 12, 15
days to shoot one episode.
ALAN SEALES: So we're
about to see season--
episode 1, season 4 this Sunday.
Are Is the whole season done?
Are you still filming?
LORI MCCREARY: We are
on 8, 4-08, episode 8.
And this will-- we
shot episode 1 in July,
and it's airing in September.
But by the time we get to
Christmas, we'll have shot--
I think it's episode
14, and it will air--
we'll finish it on a Friday.
We'll edit it the next
Friday, and it'll air Sunday.
So it's very quick.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
And obviously, things happen
in real life, we'll call it.
You know, for example, like
Tim Daly had his ski accident.
[LAUGH]
I think it was middle of
season 2 or season 3, right?
So how did that affect shooting?
Did you have to write that--
write in any changes for that?
LORI MCCREARY: Yes.
We had to-- the
writers had to go back
to two episodes that were
already written and write in.
The good news is
at that moment, we
were shooting a big action
scene where miraculously he
didn't get hurt.
So we just had him get hurt.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: That's funny.
I guess that makes sense.
You make the use of it.
LORI MCCREARY: Yeah, yeah.
It was more realistic
for the show really.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Right.
LORI MCCREARY: Not so
good for him, but--
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So Morgan, let's talk about you.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Go ahead.
ALAN SEALES: OK.
Probably more well known
as an Oscar-winning actor,
got started at the age
of nine in a school play,
won a drama competition at
age 12, performed on the radio
during high school, served
in the US Air Force,
raising to rank
Airman First Class.
You took acting
lessons, you were
a dancer in the
World's Fair, you've
been in Off-Broadway
in '67, and then
in Broadway for an all-black
version of "Hello, Dolly"
in '68.
You didn't get to
film until '71.
Why-- what made you
do that transition?
MORGAN FREEMAN: No, no.
I-- from childhood, I
wanted to be in the movies.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
But how do you get into movies?
ALAN SEALES: Off-Broadway?
Broadway?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Well, yeah.
I thought you could just go
to Hollywood and say, hey.
I'm here.
[LAUGHTER]
Because that's what I did.
I went to Hollywood and
I went to Paramount.
I didn't go to the studio.
I went to offices that they
had in Hollywood on Sunset.
And I-- I'm an actor, and I'm
looking for something to do,
you know?
And she said, do you
belong to a union?
No.
She said, well, you
have to join the union.
I said, well, OK.
How was that-- [INAUDIBLE]
said, all right.
So I got all the information.
I didn't have any
money, so I had
to walk to the union office.
And I walked in there and
said, I want to join the union.
They said, do you have a job?
And I said, no.
They told me I had
to be in the union.
They said, well, you
have to have a job.
So that catch-22, it
still exists, you know?
LORI MCCREARY: Still that way.
MORGAN FREEMAN:
I said, now what?
So eventually, I wound up in
school, taking acting lessons,
Acting 101, I got a D in.
[LAUGHTER]
Murmur, go ahead.
Because it's the
truth, you know?
It's like-- so I'm going
to tell you right now,
acting is not something
you can really teach.
Technique, you can, but
the actual art, you can't.
Is it an art?
LORI MCCREARY: You mean you
either have it or you don't?
Or you--
MORGAN FREEMAN: I kind
of think that-- yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Capital I, It.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
LORI MCCREARY: It.
MORGAN FREEMAN: There's
this story about--
and these things
always come from China.
But he was a wheel
maker, and this woman
wanted him to teach
her son the art.
And he said, well, I can
teach him how to make a wheel,
but I can't teach him the art.
ALAN SEALES: Hmm.
True.
So I don't know if I'm
allowed to say this,
but you just celebrated
your 80th birthday back--
MORGAN FREEMAN: You're
allowed to say that.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAN SEALES: Wonderful.
MORGAN FREEMAN: I feel
like Muhammad Ali.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
So now you're 80, and then you
credit your first breakout role
to be the role of Fast Black
in "Street Smart" in '87
at the age of 50.
So you were acting for decades--
MORGAN FREEMAN: That was
my movie breakout role.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
So would you ever--
do you ever consider
returning back to theater?
Do you miss that sort of thing?
Or do you like--
do you like acting in
front of the camera now?
Or--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Did you
know what I just said,
a little bit about-- what?
A minute and a half ago?
ALAN SEALES: I don't
pay much attention.
MORGAN FREEMAN: From childhood,
I wanted to be in the movies.
In the movies.
[LAUGHTER]
Movies.
Back in '08, I
went back on stage,
and I was with Frances
McDormand and Peter Gallagher.
And I remember one night,
we came out on stage,
ready for the curtain to go up.
And we looked up there and
said, what are we doing here?
All three of us
are movie actors.
[LAUGH]
Uh-uh.
No.
I've done that-- been
there, done that, and--
ALAN SEALES: You're over it?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
It's a lot of work.
ALAN SEALES: It is.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
And I think it's
for young people.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Young people
with makeup sometimes.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: That's funny.
So do you enjoy-- now
that you're in the movies,
do you enjoy the behind
the camera or in front
of the camera--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Fair.
Let's talk about Lori.
[LAUGHTER]
So President of the
Producers Guild of America,
Co-President, Founder of the
PGA's Motion Picture Technology
Committee, sits on the
Producers Council of the PGA
and on the Technology
Committee of the American
Society of Cinematographers, a
member of the Society of Motion
Picture and Television
Engineers, SMPTE,
and the Institution of
Electrical and Electronics
Engineers, Inc., the IEEE.
In addition, were profiled
by the Hollywood Reporter
in its 100 most powerful
women in Hollywood.
Just wow.
[APPLAUSE]
And so you've joined
up with Morgan,
you've had this great
career, but your--
MORGAN FREEMAN:
Call me Svengali.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
You joined up with Svengali.
LORI MCCREARY: Yes.
ALAN SEALES: And--
Svengali Freeman?
[LAUGHTER]
And you've got this great
production career and things
that you're doing now
for CBS and for Nat Geo,
National Geographic, we'll
touch on in a little bit.
But your computer science
history, how did that even get
started?
And then why bring that
into motion pictures now?
LORI MCCREARY:
Well, so I started
when I was eight in theater.
And I thought what I was
going to do with my life was
own a theater and put
on plays for a living
until I found out that it's
hard to make money doing that.
But literally I was filling
out my college application,
and a couple nights before,
we had a computerized lighting
system in our local theater,
and the computer didn't turn on,
and I had to run it manually.
And I was kind of annoyed,
so I thought, oh, I
don't want to study theater.
I've already done it.
I'll study computer science.
So kind of a fluke to
do that, but I loved it.
And I also, like, really
dug in, because when
I went to the counselors--
I went to UCLA--
they told me I could,
like, write my own major.
And I wanted to write a
major between the arts--
the College of Fine Arts and
computer science department,
cause I thought they
were connecting.
And literally, the
counselor said to me,
you got to choose one, and you
should probably choose theater.
And I was like, OK, I will--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm going to go to
computer science.
So I got my computer science
degree, and I loved it.
And I just saw-- it was
like, just the beginning.
I'm old, a lot
older than you guys.
But it was just the beginning.
We had to build with our own
breadboards, circuit boards,
we had to build the
computer from scratch,
write with mixed machine
code to make it work.
So I loved it.
I would still do it
for a living if I
didn't love even more
telling stories I
think that make a difference.
And in our business,
our industry,
the actual making of film and
TV is still very blue collar.
We need so much
help from you guys.
There's a lot that we can do
just kind of on an enterprise
level to help us be more
efficient in filmmaking
and make better product
more efficiently.
And so that's what we've been
talking about for the last 20
years in our company.
We tried to push our
industry to go quicker
into downloading a film
when the music industry was
kind of crashing and burning.
Our industry didn't go
quick enough, I think,
but we're getting there.
And so there's a
lot of room for all
of y'all in the
entertainment business.
We need help.
ALAN SEALES: And what is the
Picture Technology Committee?
LORI MCCREARY: Motion
Picture Technology Committee,
there's a lot of--
there's 8,000 producers
in the Producers Guild,
and there were a
lot of committees
that were called new media.
So people doing kind
of short-form content
and back in the day, CD content
and DVD content, and now
online content.
But there was no
committee that looked
at the way we make
motion pictures,
the literal coming there
with our film cameras
and all the people with
a lot of paper on set,
and figure out how to
make it more streamlined.
And I would love some
cloud-based system
that we all use.
We don't have that yet.
So the Motion Picture
Technology Council
looks at all of those things
and tries to go to vendors
and asked them to help us
build systems like that.
ALAN SEALES: Wow.
I feel like you could get James
Cameron to help out with that.
LORI MCCREARY:
That would be good.
ALAN SEALES: Just more
explosions, he would say.
More technology for
more explosions.
And that has led to ClickStar.
What is that?
LORI MCCREARY:
Well, ClickStar was
a company we started
in 2005, back
before streaming
was the thing, back
before iTunes was
downloading movies.
And we were the first
downloadable movie site for--
MORGAN FREEMAN:
What was that movie?
Our music thing--
where downloading--
LORI MCCREARY: Napster.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Napster.
Anyway-- and
LORI MCCREARY:
Post-Napster, pre-iTunes.
MORGAN FREEMAN: The
idea was, figure out
a way to download movies,
but have digital rights
management--
that right?
DRM?
LORI MCCREARY: Very good.
MORGAN FREEMAN: So
that it was a safe--
safe to do when we did it.
But we were a couple of
years ahead of our time.
LORI MCCREARY: The bleeding edge
instead of the cutting edge,
so we kind of got--
ALAN SEALES: You were the
Google Glass of wearable--
LORI MCCREARY: Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
I wore Google Glass to the Emmys
the first year they came out.
I loved it.
ALAN SEALES: And do you get--
LORI MCCREARY: I got
a lot of photographs.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah?
[LAUGHTER]
Talking-- I want to go
back to "Madam Secretary"
for a little bit here.
The casting, the cast
complements itself--
complements each other so well.
And Tea Leoni is an
incredible choice
for the character of Elizabeth.
How did you find her?
And was she an obvious choice?
Or was it a hard-- was it
hard to cast Elizabeth?
[LAUGH]
MORGAN FREEMAN: No.
LORI MCCREARY: No.
She was the first person that
Nina Tassler brought up to us.
They'd been evidently
trying to get
Tea to do something
for nine years,
CBS had, and all
the other networks.
But she had-- you know,
she lives in New York,
she was raising her kids.
She was-- you know.
MORGAN FREEMAN: And
she had another show.
LORI MCCREARY: Yeah.
And actually, she had
committed to another show,
and then she read our script.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
LORI MCCREARY: And she loved it.
MORGAN FREEMAN:
That was a shoo-in.
ALAN SEALES: So she was attached
early on, it sounds like.
And then how did you
flesh out the rest?
Like, Tim Daly's great.
Patina, I knew Patina from
when she was in "Sister Act."
LORI MCCREARY: Oh.
We saw her in
"Pippin," and thought
she was just extraordinary,
and we knew we-- you know,
she's a powerhouse and
really great actor.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
So did you audition
these people,
or did you kind of
hand-pick who you wanted?
And did Morgan have to audition?
Sorry, Svengali.
Did he audition?
MORGAN FREEMAN: I did.
LORI MCCREARY: Svengali
actually auditioned.
We were doing a casting
session where he was directing,
and we needed the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court.
We had a couple names of people.
So we went through this, like,
three-hour casting session.
And then Mark Saks, the
casting director, said,
who are we going to get
to play Chief Justice?
And we both looked at
Morgan, and Morgan said--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Do you
want me to audition?
[LAUGHTER]
Would you audition?
Sure.
LORI MCCREARY: So he
literally jumped up
in front of the camera, and
we sent his tape to CBS.
And I kept getting phone calls.
Did he literally
audition for himself?
[LAUGHTER]
And he was directing, so he--
I don't know if you
had to sleep with--
MORGAN FREEMAN: I was a shoo-in.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Do you
remember the point at which
you didn't have to audition?
Was that your last audition?
MORGAN FREEMAN: After
"Street--" for movies?
ALAN SEALES: Mm-hmm.
MORGAN FREEMAN: "Street Smart."
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
LORI MCCREARY: Wow.
MORGAN FREEMAN: I didn't.
But what happened after "Street
Smart" was I kept getting--
I play the "pim-p."
[LAUGHTER]
And I got a nomination
for playing a pimp.
Try that.
But I kept getting these
scripts for these kinds of guys,
you know?
They said-- well, they
thought that actually I
had been brought
in off the street,
and just happened to be one of
those, you know, lucky things.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: And the people
in New York, because I'd
been doing everything
from [? Dunton ?] Theater
to Broadway in New York said,
well, this guy is a Broad--
is a Shakespearean
actor, you know?
You know, you don't know him.
Because they were--
who was that?
So what was I saying?
ALAN SEALES: Last
time you auditioned.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Oh.
Yeah.
I didn't have to
audition after that.
[LAUGH]
That was just--
ALAN SEALES: And you
auditioned for yourself.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Did you give
yourself any audition notes?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah, I
use the KISS principle.
ALAN SEALES: Keep
It Simple Stupid.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yep.
And the dra-- this is a drama.
The show is a drama for
pretty much most of the time.
But do you have any
funny moments on set?
Like, what are some
of the funniest times
you've had during filming?
MORGAN FREEMAN: I'm
not going to tell you.
[LAUGHTER]
Bad language.
ALAN SEALES: It's all right.
We're all adults here.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Tea
doesn't like to fuck up.
[LAUGHTER]
She doesn't.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah?
MORGAN FREEMAN: No.
And when she does,
that's what she says.
ALAN SEALES: And that's funny?
MORGAN FREEMAN:
That's funny to me.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: So
collective single moment.
So we will have time, if
you want to start up with--
lining up for a few
audience questions,
we can take a few
here if anybody has
anything for the two of them.
The kids on the show,
Kathrine, Evan, and Wallace,
they've-- over the last four
years, you've known them.
Obviously, probably
since before the filming
started with the auditioning,
and you've seen them grow up.
Have you seen changes to
the characters based on them
getting older in real life?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah,
the middle-- the--
LORI MCCREARY: Kathrine.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Kathrine.
I think she's
grown tremendously.
LORI MCCREARY: She hadn't done
a lot of acting before that,
and so I think having--
being on the show
and Tim and Tea are
amazing with them.
And so she's really
kind of taken it on.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: It was fun.
Yeah, I always enjoy
watching kids, like,
for long-running shows,
just seeing them--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Develop.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: How they-- yeah.
LORI MCCREARY: Oh, no.
And Evan is, like, taller
than Tea almost now.
ALAN SEALES: Right.
Right.
MORGAN FREEMAN: And
their voice is deepening.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Question over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you both for coming.
I'm so excited to
see you both here.
And I must admit that I haven't
watched "Madam Secretary" yet,
but I was a big--
MORGAN FREEMAN: What
are you talking about?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm still working
my way up to the 21st century,
but it's the first
show on my list,
so I'm excited to get started.
But when you were talking about
kind of all of the writing
that goes into it
constantly, thinking
about contemporary political
events and this being
a political show, how much do
you let kind of the real world
and, like, what people
who are watching it
are probably thinking about
and see in actual politics
influence the direction
that the show takes?
LORI MCCREARY: You
want me to take it or--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yes, please.
LORI MCCREARY: I
think that we do--
what we do is we get inspired.
So last season, we
ended-- the season finale
was all about NATO.
And when we were
conceiving of what
the show would be, there
was a lot of talk about,
should NATO be disbanned?
And there were-- and we felt,
even in the writers' room,
maybe we all didn't
really understand NATO
and why it started, and what the
ramifications of not having it
were.
So we built that
into a storyline
in the last two
episodes of last season.
And the season premiere
is all about fake news,
which I think we all deal
with hearing about every day.
So we're inspired by the topics.
And what we love to do is kind
of really unpack them and try
to look at both sides.
Our president as an independent.
He's not a Democrat
or a Republican,
so we try to stay away from
the politicizing of issues.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Given your computer science
background and artistic theater
background, was computer
animation something
you were interested in, or
something your production
company would pursue?
LORI MCCREARY: We do have a
couple animation projects.
One of the things
that it helped me do
is really look
deeply at our effects
budgets and our animation
budgets to really see.
Because I was surprised when
I came from computer science
that, you know, you
could spend $80 million
doing effects for a movie.
And I was like, I could
start a lot of companies
for $80 million.
And I'm just going
to get this film.
So we are interested
in animation.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah, over here.
AUDIENCE: Lori, in
passing you said
that the middle class
of film is shrinking.
What does that mean?
LORI MCCREARY: What it
means is the middle class
in terms of the budget.
So there are-- you know,
you can make a movie
for less than a
million, or you can make
a movie for over $100 million.
The $10 million and
under budget movies
are fairly easy to get greenlit
today, and $100 million
and over, because
there's usually
two big stars and a big brand.
The middle class, "The
Bucket Lists," the--
help me with another movie.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Um, um--
LORI MCCREARY:
"Million Dollar Baby."
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah,
LORI MCCREARY:
The kind of movies
that would cost normally
$30 to $60 million,
they're hard to find
a home right now.
All the studios used to
have independent divisions,
and that's where the
independent movies would go.
But the studios are really
looking for the big brand
boy, four-quadrant movies,
or the lower budget movies
that you can-- it's
hard to lose money on.
So the middle class, you'll
see a lot of my friends
who are movie makers are
taking the subjects--
"Million Dollar Baby"-type
subjects and putting them
on television now as, you
know, either limited series
or a series.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
LORI MCCREARY: Sure.
ALAN SEALES: I want to
give a quick plug to you
guys' book, as you're
also promoting something
for National Geographic.
You both produced, of
course, "The Story of God"
with Svengali Freeman.
But now you have
something else premiering
called "The Story of
Us" with Morgan Freeman.
What is that about, and
why did you do that?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Well,
the why is while we
were doing "The Story
of God," and you
know, we went around the
world, talking to people,
meeting people, getting
all these wonderful stories
and inputs about humans.
So I said, we should do that.
We should talk about man.
We should do a story on man.
And then we had to put
that in the pot and let it
simmer, let it boil.
And we came out with
not the story of man,
but "The Story of Us."
We're talking about
us now, not mankind
as an evolutionary thing.
That was the genesis
of that, I think.
Am I right about this?
LORI MCCREARY: You are right.
And we-- because
tribalism and nationalism
seems to be brewing
all around the planet,
we decided to look at the
big topics that are trend--
having us trend towards that.
And we're looking at long--
thousands of years of
history in what we're doing.
So we look at love, we
look at war and peace,
we look at rebels.
Turns out rebels are a great
way to help us get society back
on track.
So it was a fun--
it was a fun series.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
I mean, you've spoken with
some amazing people like Megan
Phelps-Roper from Westboro
Baptist Church and Joshua
Coombes from-- the founder of
dosomethingfornothing movement,
and then even--
name drop-- Bill Clinton.
[LAUGH]
So how did you decide--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Paul
Kagame of Rwanda.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
How did you decide
who you wanted
to focus the episodes on?
MORGAN FREEMAN: I didn't have
anything to do with that.
ALAN SEALES: No?
MORGAN FREEMAN: No.
ALAN SEALES: Did you?
LORI MCCREARY: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
We have great
associate producers
who basically gave us about
120 different stories to choose
from for our six episodes.
So we pulled about 40--
some of the best stories,
the stories that were really--
felt, like, emotionally resonant
and would fit within the season
1 of "The Story of Us."
ALAN SEALES: That's fun.
Would you ever do anything
like the story of Google
with Morgan Freeman?
[LAUGHTER]
The The story of who?
LORI MCCREARY: Google.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Have
you heard of it?
MORGAN FREEMAN: I was just--
I was just looking at the
musical thing over there.
LORI MCCREARY: It's nice.
Yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: And the "Starry
Night--" what do you call that?
As you're walking in,
there's a Google--
there's--
ALAN SEALES: The doodle?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Painted-- yeah.
Like van Gogh's "Starry Night."
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
See, you didn't
think I knew that.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I use Google all the time.
ALAN SEALES: Well--
[LAUGHTER]
I got connections--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Google is--
Google is now--
it's now in action.
ALAN SEALES: It's a verb, yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Which they
don't want us to say, but--
MORGAN FREEMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN SEALES: Sorry, it is.
Yeah, let's take a
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I actually have two.
So my first is, what are
your guys' favorite TV shows
or movies out there right
now besides "Madam Secretary"
that you watch?
And then my second one was
there are so many political
shows out there right now,
both dramas and comedies.
How do you guys deal
with the competition
in keeping the storyline fresh?
MORGAN FREEMAN: There
is no competition.
[LAUGHTER]
We are the only show that has
a female secretary of state.
So-- duh.
ALAN SEALES: Mic drop.
[LAUGHTER]
What was the first one?
LORI MCCREARY: Favorite show.
ALAN SEALES: Your favorite show.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Favorite show or
movie right now.
MORGAN FREEMAN:
Favorite show or movie?
Gosh.
I just watched--
I binge-watched-- and I can't
even remember the total title--
but it's on Netflix, and
it's Jane Fonda and--
LORI MCCREARY: Lily Tomlin.
MORGAN FREEMAN: What she said.
Lily Tomlin, Martin
Sheen, and Sam Waterston.
ALAN SEALES: What is it?
AUDIENCE: "Grace and Frankie."
MORGAN FREEMAN: Huh?
LORI MCCREARY:
"Gracie and Frankie."
ALAN SEALES: "Grace
and Frankie."
"Frankie."
MORGAN FREEMAN: "Frankie."
I had the "Gracie" part.
"Frankie and Grace."
ALAN SEALES: That sounded
like frogs in a pond.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: Just
an outstanding show.
I'm just enthralled watching it.
Wonderful performances, great
writing, way out concept.
That's mine.
And she's got one too.
ALAN SEALES: What's yours?
LORI MCCREARY: Well, I
have a lot of favorites.
What I just recently
finished watching
was season 1 of
"Handmaid's Tale."
ALAN SEALES: Mm.
LORI MCCREARY: Did
you guys see that?
Oh.
Yeah.
Intense, and I couldn't
stop watching it.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
Very good.
MORGAN FREEMAN: All right?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LORI MCCREARY: Thanks.
ALAN SEALES: Yeah,
question over here.
AUDIENCE: Do you
license your voices
for use in
text-to-speech engines?
Like--
[LAUGHTER]
--Google Assistant.
LORI MCCREARY: He wants to know
if you would license your voice
to use in a
text-to-speech engine.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Depends.
LORI MCCREARY: It depends.
ALAN SEALES: He works
on Google Assistant.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: Oh, does he?
ALAN SEALES: Yeah.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Well, I got
to tell you, that depends.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: If you
want to sound smart,
you want to be the voice of
Assistant, not the other guys.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Oh really?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
We can talk about that.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: I
actually was planning
on giving you the Google
Play terms and conditions,
and just having you read
that for 30 minutes,
but then I actually
wrote questions.
[LAUGHTER]
Because we would have
all listened to that too.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I was just
wondering, how, if at all,
did the results of the
presidential election
last year change the
way you were envisioning
the development of
the plot for this show
over the next few seasons?
MORGAN FREEMAN: You know,
you watch something like that
and ask yourselves,
can we use it?
The answer is a universal no.
LORI MCCREARY: I mean, the
good news for us, I think,
was we started the
show three years
before the
presidential election.
So we imagined we'd started the
show two election cycles ahead
of where we were then currently.
So in our world, the current
administration never existed.
So we choose to look at our show
as a more aspirational version
of maybe what we're seeing
in real life right now,
and we try to--
we try to create something
that on Sunday nights,
you could watch, feel
good about the world,
and sleep a little better.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
MORGAN FREEMAN: Well done.
ALAN SEALES: Do you
have anything to add?
No?
MORGAN FREEMAN: No.
ALAN SEALES: Sweet.
All right.
Two more quick questions.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi Morgan.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: My name is Fez.
And you clearly have
such a celebrated career
with so many different roles
that people recognize you for,
right?
I can't think of any other
voice or character that's
been associated with God as much
or as frequently as you have.
How does that feel?
Is that empowering?
Is that strange?
Do people come up to
you, asking about that?
Or am I the first--
the guy asking this question.
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: It's
gotten to be a PITA.
LORI MCCREARY: A what?
MORGAN FREEMAN: PITA.
LORI MCCREARY: Pain in the--
[LAUGHTER]
MORGAN FREEMAN: You got it.
It's terrible to be
so closely associated
with the idea of God.
It tends to reduce the
importance of the idea of God,
to walk around saying, this
guy reminds you, you know?
I'd rather not.
Here again, we're
talking about something
that's good on one
side and really,
really bad on the other side.
You like getting recognition
for the work that you've done,
but some of it's a
little over the top.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Cool.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Cool.
Yes.
Last question.
AUDIENCE: I'm a huge
fan of the show,
so thank you so much for coming.
And since starting to watch
it, I have cut my cord
and I don't have cable, right?
So it's the world of
Netflix, world of Hulu.
CBS is on its own.
So I just wondered,
as creators--
and you mentioned
film friends are
moving on to this TV world--
as creators, how are you--
how do you feel about
this whole thing?
Like, how do you feel about CBS
being separate from the others?
And does it disappoint you, or
is it exciting, and how do you
feel?
LORI MCCREARY: You want
to go, or you want me to?
MORGAN FREEMAN: No.
I don't even know what
we're talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
LORI MCCREARY: She was asking,
because a lot of people
are cutting their cords,
they either don't have CBS
or you have to subscribe
to CBS All Access
to see "Madam Secretary."
It's not yet on Netflix.
There was just
announced last week
that Netflix just did
a big deal with us,
so that's the good news.
We went into syndication
early, so that's good.
But personally,
as a filmmaker, I
love the fact that
there are so many
places that we can
create content for.
So I think it allows more
people to get-- it used
to be you had seven places.
If you were a filmmaker, you
had to go to those seven places.
You had to know
someone there, and you
had to kind of get
funneled into these places.
There are hundreds
of places now.
And quite frankly, you
can make your own content
and put it on the internet.
So we love it.
We've been a big
proponent of people
being able to access
content any time, any place.
I would love it if our
films and our TV content
are more accessible to everyone.
It's going to take a while,
because it's all still flushing
out and people have
business models.
Like, CBS has a
business model, and they
know what they're
going to make and how
they're going to make it.
And if you break it
up, it's going to--
if you break up, like,
network television,
it could break the whole thing.
So they're doing it slowly.
And CBS is one of the first to
have their own CBS All Access.
So I applaud them
for dipping their toe
in before some of the others.
And I'm just-- I'm just
excited to see what's next.
MORGAN FREEMAN: You
know why she's so smart?
[LAUGHTER]
She had a-- has an
outstanding set of parents.
LORI MCCREARY: I do.
MORGAN FREEMAN:
Really created her.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Literally?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: Yes.
LORI MCCREARY: Literally.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
ALAN SEALES: All right.
So last question from me.
Looking back on your
careers, both of you,
is there a single
defining moment
that you can look
at and say, this
is why I am today,
because of that moment?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
When I was 12 years old,
I pulled a chair out
from under a girl.
[LAUGHTER]
And she chased me.
I thought she was
really going to kill me.
[LAUGH]
And I was collared by an English
teacher who frogmarched me
down a hall and shoved me into
a room and said, here he is.
And that was my
first opportunity
at getting on stage as an actor.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: And you enjoyed it?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Immensely.
I got my first best actor award.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: Detention?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Detention?
ALAN SEALES: For pulling the
chair out from under the girl?
MORGAN FREEMAN: Well,
I tell that story now,
and she was at my 80th
birthday party, grinning.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: That's funny.
Lori, do you have a moment?
LORI MCCREARY: I honestly--
not just because he's here.
I think meeting Morgan was the
defining moment in my career.
I came from--
[LAUGHTER]
--I was making my first movie.
I didn't know if it's
what I was going to be
doing the rest of my life.
And And thankfully,
when we connected,
I immediately got
something that is
hard to get in our
business, which
is when I walked into a room,
he, even if he wasn't there,
walked in before me.
So people automatically gave
me more credit for being smart,
full of integrity, everything
you see this man is.
And so I've been able--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Not bad looking.
LORI MCCREARY: Yeah.
Good looking.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So I would credit
connecting with Mr. Freeman.
ALAN SEALES: That's amazing.
Well, thank you both for being--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Did
you write that down?
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN SEALES: It's now
out there on Googleverse.
MORGAN FREEMAN: OK.
ALAN SEALES: The
Googleverse, yes.
Yeah, so you can follow
Lori McCreary on Twitter
@LoriMcCreary.
Morgan, you aren't on Twitter.
MORGAN FREEMAN: Nope.
ALAN SEALES: Nope.
You can follow the
show @MadamSecretary.
Catch "The Story of
Us" with Morgan Freeman
on National Geographic on
October 11, which is very soon,
of course.
And then season 4
of "Madam Secretary"
premieres this
Sunday, October 8.
Everyone please go watch it.
Help me thank them
for showing up today.
[APPLAUSE]